how the government my name welcome back
to another set of I was gonna say cry of
fear I do do do
alright let's just do this I think I
will have to store it and like something
else played mostly green gobbling I
didn't play you let's play alright [ __ ]
yeah I'm Green Goblin frontflips well I
just [ __ ] out the [ __ ] leg holy [ __ ]
Oh Green Goblin ah come on man you got a
[ __ ] huge dick or a leg I don't know
what that is
ah son of a [ __ ] am i giving birth to a
man god damn what's gone hi Green Goblin
we got a second trap front-flip damn it
come on you just take a [ __ ] whoa Green
Goblin Green Goblin are you okay man I
don't think you made it
um what'd you say um that you only meant
well very hard I know what else is very
hard that is too narrow that's what she
said alright here we got a blah
god damn that hurts daddy a choking man
I'm Chucky ah ah okay yes this is
totally I'm humping your dead body
whoa what love it dad shuts what are you
doing yeah
alright I'll let you go first you little
prick no ah yeah yeah ah come on son gum
PewDiePie brofist I even notice all
right here we go again
grab that [ __ ] yes
help me out of this son I'm stuck whoa I
like this precision of course you do
yeah little homo uh random - Oh [ __ ]
Santa card fraud flip Santa power no
[ __ ] it
Oh got a present for you [ __ ]
yeah I made it holy [ __ ] that was
awesome Santa there we go first a bad
drone part yeah yeah yeah yeah our leg
that's okay see you like leg in another
life perhaps it's got a bad FBS here
know if it's a map for me hunt that [ __ ]
here we go were front flip out out I
lost my help grab it I kiss it to erect
Oh AJ grab a gap I got it front flap
acrobatics leg don't you blame me leg
don't you lay me come here leg I got you
like no come back leg leg no you [ __ ]
I got it
what am I supposed to do what the hell
is going on here hold up
all right come here leg leg leg what the
hell
language gone like where did he go grab
on up that face blood as confusing
I wonder where leg went Choi is in a
better place right now bombed in my
sandwich I miss their sandwich doesn't
have turkey net
frickin get it right inside of a
bachelor's vital ah ah this is what
happens when I don't get my jacket ID
badge yeah [ __ ] this great but that
is wrong with my body a date stoner
Tony's not Turkey [ __ ] is wrong with my
body
I'm prey free ah saw sting ah another
slam dunk I'm a responsible dad and
welcome to grab a table blanket as lame
I'll throw a no all right lady put down
my boy I don't see a difference let me
check your anus now you definitely have
a vagina there all right I'll ate it
Popeye all right next up Mara BM I love
ya I love ya
there we go don't come back here you
little that's right die I went to hell
get off me [ __ ] legs stuck you like
this bye I mean girl don't come back
keep [ __ ] dying
oh well it hurts Bingham that gotta suck
to be yeah doesn't it yes you're all dad
that was pretty cool when I don't even
[ __ ] know and I don't even know the
control a it's ad other very car car
you fell not so cool now entry all right
come on ah son of a [ __ ] goddamn dad
Pig - Ryder Etna why can't I run this
[ __ ] rainbow come on man
there we go there we go he threw up in
its fight car wait what
pointless bottom Oh pointless you will
bring a surprise alright Carl
dad I don't know about this shut up and
wait dear little [ __ ]
okay I'm sorry
I whip my hair back and forth I whip my
hair back dad for Daniel shut up I'm
singing I whip my hair back and butt
gotta wanna wait anymore shut up
God okay fine hope you're happy now we
miss a table flip I like trains ruining
your anything in there
hey I it's bouncing God stop this shut
it's not cold I'm just kidding all right
slow a parking meter
what's wrap catch
die you little [ __ ] Guerrero I'm God for
your dad you [ __ ] me huh
hope you liked it all right
nice job son kill them all in 3d why not
I love the little why is it shut up
don't talk about Megan Fox there we go
you little [ __ ]
how do you even walking that's right
yeah a dead paper I'll go over here Hey
Oh haters gonna hate
i laughs curse you so what the hell but
L is that little boy doing I didn't know
that goddamn he's still going I don't
need two legs to walk I just want to put
a [ __ ] done you can go sir thank you
where how does I don't walk off me well
then whoa
sugar nice walk yeah chicks don't
synchronize walking my wife oh are you
doing Rocka how it comes there's
possible that yeah I thought I split I
spread white I split aah
not in my ass huh aah okay I think we
get the point
all right this one
pity doesn't move and get off me all
right sure
Maris what are you doing here hi patty I
love you what oh that is a mer Wow
Jason make it aa Megan Fox Shara Shamu
pop rare I can't do this
hey any landing mr. Sherr awesome oh I
don't care
I'm sure hardcore killed either grab
that [ __ ] Bieber your time has come
ha ha ha ah [ __ ] yeah yeah ah my freakin
spine went out without freaking worth it
bike race let's do it whoa Dan you're no
Shane you're so slow it's cuz yourself
at good you're not gonna be to me
ha ha gotta go in for ya that's right
sad that's my boy - oh yeah yeah so slow
ha ha oh [ __ ] oh god oh that's a problem
you suck bye I hate you we're dead right
here we go gonna do this [ __ ]
hardcore style front no front flaps I
don't know why L is do front flips in
the end your noon look at that [ __ ]
[ __ ] gangster styling this [ __ ] yeah
ha a female you think you're gonna beat
me look at this front flap but that is a
shut up but he'll you say anything more
I [ __ ] climb this mountain like I did
it anyway but then I'm supposed to be in
school and learn stuff you don't need to
learn stuff look there's a cactus I
taught you something somebody reached a
fella that's [ __ ] no unrested
reaches before me castle siege
this about a horse [ __ ]
yes I'm gonna horse this is beautiful
go shane dawson shanedawsontv shane
dawson hate when you make my heads float
come on man what is this space make the
horse break up to accelerate go hard go
shane dawson go for it have you seen my
heart man
name is Shane Dawson come on whoa whoa
shane dawson is out of control due to
the truth damn that Shane Dawson he's
trained Lee the barrel what the [ __ ] are
you doing here
eat them Shane I don't even [ __ ] care
that's - a dozen Stan's people it's
[ __ ] outta control man
I haters gonna hate
Shane Dawson's gonna skate watch it [ __ ]
man here we go here we go out the window
holy [ __ ] this horse is epic each horse
legs' fetches what What did he say he
teleported away
no now she does in his best you don't ah
[ __ ] he took my head well that was that
I guess I wanna try this again hello how
are you [ __ ] runs it looks awesome
come on Shane Dawson whoa [ __ ] Shane
doesn't stop making my head explode
all right I'll see you in a couple
seconds back Shane Dawson you have speed
man look at his legs
oh my god no no this like Shay doesn't
come back out the window look at his
legs finger guy I can pop haters gotta
hate haters gotta this is how i ride my
heart's betches all right the finish was
right there so anyway epic [ __ ]
levels more horse level please command
it but anyway like and food if you
enjoyed it subscribe to Cobra today and
I'll see you next episode of whatever I
make sales I'm rose wrap this up
Thank You votes for all this apart you
know it's coming I'm gonna punch it now
I'm recording here to hell what
girlfriend is drunk as always but anyway